hi my name is Manoj Agarwal with royal
thanks we're doing the question on that
been asked is can India be a local
superpower my answer to that is India is
already a global superpower we are a
nuclear superpower and that program has
been cemented with other super powers
like the United States and is rolling
ahead
we are the economic superpower we are
talking about three traits which are
potentially in excess of China in the
foreseeable future
we are talking about a human capital
race which India is I think it is the
largest democracy in the world today so
there are there are of course a few
aspects in terms of infrastructure in
terms of healthcare in terms of
education that we need to sort out but I
am absolutely confident that if you were
to sort of revisit this question in 10
years time they would be absolutely
nobody who would actually be even asking
this question thanks